hey hey what's up this is deloney with
the dr john dolone
show the show for you by you
about you we talk about relationships
and parenting and mental health we talk
about
figuring out what to do next when you
just don't know what to do
getting help with how to be a better
husband how to be a better wife how to
be a better girlfriend boyfriend
how to figure out what in the world is
going on these days and we got a special
episode for you today
if there is one recurring comment over
and over again
on the book reviews on youtube on
instagram on all the all the internet
stuffs
it's delaney talks about taxes too much
oh my gosh please shut up about texas
okay we get it dolan you're freaking
from texas get it get it get it
and then whenever i i co-host the dave
ramsey show with dave
his little side hustle show that goes
out to bajillions of millions of people
they're all running their mouth
oh my gosh daloni texas we get it you're
from the
you don't even live there you live in
tennessee isn't tennessee texas granddad
hey you listen here texas doesn't have a
granddad that's kind of ridiculous
somebody actually told me that
but listen um i finally i had enough
of it you guys will not stop talking to
me about
texas texas so here's what i did i got
it
i got a full-sized texas flag and i went
and got
the ambassador the living mascot
of the state of texas him and i share a
moment or two in our lives
because everybody from texas knows
everybody in case you didn't know that
but today on the show we have the one
and only oscar award
winning was on one of the greatest
television shows in
history just wrote a brand new
best-selling book called green lights we
have the one and only matthew
mcconaughey
with delony and we're going to figure
some stuff out we're going to talk about
parenting we're going to talk about
mental health we're going to talk about
what's going on in the country we're
going to talk about all of it we're
going to talk about football because
when two texans get in a room we've got
to talk about football for crying out
loud
we're going to talk about all of it and
it's awesome and it's hilarious he's a
great guy
if you're watching this on youtube
you're going to struggle with who's
better looking i'm not gonna lie
it's tough it's tough um does he have
perfect teeth
yes does he super ripped yes
um is his hair way cooler than mine mine
looks kind of like
um i'm growing lord vader's helmet and
his
is long and beautiful but beyond those
things
beyond his basic facial features his
structure of his body in his hair
i think i've got him beat on the who's
better looking part
all of that and more on the dr john
deloney show
the one and only matthew mcconaughey
here we go check it out
so i want to thank you for your time he
on this show we talk about mental health
and relationships
and living full and whole lives and
i'm trying to cut through the nonsense
and some of the drivel
in the mental health landscape and
your book was a blast you really tap
into some universal truths about living
well and honestly and fully and i want
to dig into some of my favorite parts
of the book but i want to start here
with an important green light
if you will in my life and you are a
part of it
uh you and me and i think there's i
don't know give or take 80 000 or so
other people and i'm positive that you
and i share this together so tell me if
i'm crazy
i'm a father a husband and all that but
this is one of my top fivers
i'm gonna go back to november 1 2008
it was a cold beautiful night in
lubbock texas and mac brown's got his
hands on his knees
and the exquisite colt mccoy has already
got his helmet off
ready to celebrate and if i remember
correctly you were pacing the sidelines
rallying the troops up
and graham harrell had one more pass and
he rolled out and crabtree made that
catch
and tiptoed and for many of us there at
lubbock texas many of us red raiders man
our lives were complete for a moment and
it's been a steady free fall since then
but that was the moment were you there
was am i crazy oh yes
i was there that was me let me tell you
what happened on last place so i'm
sitting there
my wife camilla and i are there i'm
holding our newborn levi
texas you know we think we're going to
stop you
from scoring right here game's over we
win
and the state trooper who i knew from
the team from who had traveled with us
the longhorns he comes up and he goes
hey mr mcconaughey goes
you might want to walk over there to the
uh the tunnel because
if the crazy happens and the blue score
here
this crowd storm in the field and it
might not be safe
and i was like whoa didn't think of that
great idea so i went
hustling yelling at the team come on
here we go hustling all the way to the
tunnel
just as i arrived at the opening of the
tunnel
i heard the roar no way you missed the
catch
oh i missed it live i had my back was it
i was running with levi
and guess who i saw the first person
that came into the tunnel who's that
sally brown maxwell
ears kill her eyes and she goes and i
went
they scored oh yes
and oh yeah so and a good thing i got to
feel because
yes all of lubbock texas went on
brother listen i was standing um in the
in the box
and i saw grown men 80 year old men
they were weeping is this was the moment
man
all the failed cotton harvest all of it
came down to this sketch in this run man
that was it
i'm kind of disappointed that you what
for your for
your for the sake of your child you turn
your back on your longhorns but it is
what it is right
that's fine that's fine i guess do you
miss my glitch
with every ounce of my being man
i understand at some point you and i
have to write a letter and get mac and
mike back
in their rightful places but that's a
whole other story
oh man so man you put together this
this book was a blast to to dig into and
from start to finish and some of it rang
so true to me
just growing up in in texas
and splitting time between the houston
area and west texas
i want to start here we live in a
culture of extremes right we got denial
or victimization either or no
in-betweens
and one of the themes throughout this
book is this
conscious choice it felt like a
conscious choice to
always be looking forward and backward
at the same time
consciously choosing every day to not be
a victim
to whatever life's throw whatever life
throws at you
and i gotta know where does that
strength where does that perspective
come from because it's so
counter-cultural and for folks who
live in the space of other people's pain
it's truth it's reality right
well i think i realized pretty early on
well one when i say this resilience was
be one of my top three things that that
that
was ingrained in me by my parents uh
you were taught to get relative very
quickly meaning like you you're
griping and hemming and hawn about your
ratty tennis shoes
and how you need a new pair and my mom
would just snap at us and go you know
you're sitting there crying about no
shoes i'm gonna introduce you to the boy
with no feet
[Laughter]
um so she would baseline you know we get
up in a bad mood
she'd sit there and go like where do you
get off being in a bad mood
there was no guarantee the sun was going
to rise this morning you just got
another day
that would have guaranteed so she would
go to the absolute
baseline if i mean of what you should be
appreciative
for so that was ingrained in early on uh
then i think i learned that you know
a lot of times if i say hey and i said
yes i have been the victim but i don't
feel like i've ever been i've been
victimized but i have never felt like a
victim
what i mean by that that does not mean
that i'm denying that i was victimized
but the alternative i mean if i deny
that i'm a victim if i say no no no
you're not getting me on that i'm not
i'm not going to play the victim on that
that does not deny the the crisis or
deny the fact that i may have been
victimized
and i think that's a fallacy that people
think the the the
people can lean into uh
here's here's an example when i talk
about the metaphor of green
lights all right and the art of catching
the green light is actually at the
yellow light
when do you pause and give yourself a
red light
and dwell in a situation that may be
uncomfortable or do you put your pedal
to the metal and blow through that
yellow light and say i ain't giving that
crisis credit
well you need both right you need to
stop and go no i need to slow
i'm i need to check in i need to
recalibrate i need to
check in with who i am in this
relationship or with myself for a career
but other times we too often in society
does this a lot
we see we stop we slow down at every
yellow light
which then turns red and we find
ourselves dwelling in the victimization
of oh i'm in a red light when actually
we're dwelling in something that's like
we should have never given that crisis
credit
i'm not i should have put the pedal to
the metal and ran that yellow light and
turned it green by running it
so sometimes i think we slow down too
much and give crisis too much credit
and then obviously sometimes if we're
just blowing through all the yellow
lights we're not evolving as people if
we're just
if we're blowing through the yellows and
making them green by putting the pedal
to the metal
we're not growing so it's a combination
of the two
but you know i don't see the upside
a lot of times in playing
the victim
i love the acknowledgement it's both
right it's both and i
absolutely love that beyond having
an extraordinary mother who who
man was really intentional about passing
that along
how do we how do we communicate that to
kids in our schools how do we
communicate that to
um kids that aren't our kids that are in
our churches that are in our
neighborhoods
how do we pass that resilience along
well that's a great question and i'm i'm
challenged with it every day as a parent
you know and i think all parents are um
you know the more
actually i believe that generosity can
breed gratitude
can breed responsibility responsibility
breeds freedom
but it takes those first to the
generosity and the gratitude of giving
and being thankful for
to create more things to be thankful for
give us more things that we respect in
our life that we
say no i have that i've given that value
man and when i give something value
have the gratitude for it i'm taking
more responsibility for caring for that
and giving a damn about it
yes a child whether it's you whether
it's a friend whether it's someone's
condition
and now if i take responsibility for
that we can start to do the work
and either make choices to go forward or
sacrifice things that will give us more
freedom
tomorrow um you know it's
it's you know everyone goes oh it's a
different world these days and yeah
it it it is i mean with you know now
more than ever
our children you know take a snapshot of
themselves or some part of themselves
and put it out there in the world
and and and then wait what is the world
gonna think about it
what are all these strangers out there
that i don't know gonna think about it
and if they come back with thumbs up
i'm gonna have a great day if they come
back with thumbs down
i'm feeling depressed i don't like who i
am i'm a loser
well that's not the place to find your
identity amen that's right man
out there that that you don't know who
are on the sidelines for a reason
because they're on the sidelines you
know what i mean so
i would also say this fail more
the world tells you don't fail because
you'll be embarrassed
and we're all going to say nana and
abuba at you well again those people
saying that they're on the sidelines for
a reason
because they're not in the game the
people who are really in the game
love to see someone fail and get back up
i've gotten success and achieved things
in my life
not because i succeeded at it but
because
i've actually gotten jobs
was chosen in front of the person who
succeeded the first time at it
i was chosen because i failed got back
up got back up fail got back up
and the person who's making the choice
goes i know the guy over here
did it right the first time and he's in
but i want this charlie hustle over here
yeah
yeah that's character baby that's right
yeah and and it's not always you know
that way but you can get places by
that that resilience and people will
notice someone who goes i'm going to try
again
i'm not quitting um and i think i think
i think one is just every look we all
got to notice our children gotta
understand
this is this thing life is a rodeo man
and we're on the bull and
we're all trying to get our eight
seconds it ain't easy it ain't supposed
to be
and if nobody was wrong how the hell do
we know what was right
so come on get up it's not the end all
be all know the world is out there
telling you nan and booboo you screwed
up we didn't like this
well you know what
that's right so here's a veiled parent
question
that i'm going to pretend is for the
audience but it's really just two dads
talking here
i got a 10 year old son hank and a
five-year-old daughter josephine
and one of the things i loved in your
book is
your parents had and i've got capital
letters here in my notes
they had expectations for you
right they had expectations they
expected you to live by the family codes
they expected you to do what they said
and sometimes i love the expectations
right because every family's got their
outspoken ones and then they're
like this is the way we the way we do
things right
but we live in a culture run by children
where parents are trying to catch up
with their kids and make sure
everybody's smiling and happy what
advice do you have for
parents trying to navigate that
responsibility
to their kids i'm often telling people
over and over
this world's desperate for adults to
step up and say no to their kids and
show their kids that they love them
what's some advice you got for parents
good man
participation trophies are doing a
disservice to our kids
come on it's a lie right now it's
it's it's it's so irresponsible to them
because the real world don't give
participation trophies so soon as
they're out of the house
and they're out there thinking oh all
they got to do is show up to to get it
to get the trophy in life life goes
and and you may even get you may it may
even get bloody and you learn that whoa
it's harsh at us i'm saying it's a rodeo
i'm not trying to scare
i don't think we need to scare our
children into you better do this and if
you don't win you're not worth no that's
not the point
um look you know
if we're not we want to be we want to be
friends with our kids sure
but man i know the the parents i know
that are that's their first priority i
want to be my
kids best friend at the sacrifice of
being the father of the mother
most of those kids are turds man that's
exactly right i tell folks a lot man
get your own friends dude be their mom
and dad that
you don't need they need it and let's
give ourselves
adults let's give ourselves you said
let's give ourselves more credit if we
don't know better in circulation
situations
what the hell is evolution for that's
exactly right
[Laughter]
we're going through that and i
understand they're going to go through
it a different way
but it's that old thing about look i
look at like a tree limb kids aren't
afraid
of heights until they fall right so
when you're in the backyard and they're
climbing that tree
and they're out on that land that you're
like that's pretty damn high man if they
fall there
measure like well they fall from there
they're not going to break their arm but
they're going to get bruised and
scratching and we're going to see some
tears
maybe that's a good limb to let them
keep walking
when they get way up there we're like oh
boy they don't come back with this one
right
that's maybe when we need to step in and
go hey come on over here come here check
this out come on down a minute right you
know what i mean
down but we don't want to pull them off
the lower limbs so quickly
pull them off the lower limbs too
quickly before they can go i mean i went
to school i passed all the tests
made my a's what do i remember
what i experienced what i tried out and
failed at
what i tried out and was embarrassed of
what i tried out and succeeded at
i remember you know what
what what what happened the consequence
of the situation that i got to
experience
not more so than i did the one i learned
from the book
and if we're it's i think it's important
for all of us to want
we want our kids to be able to go out
and negotiate life right
and we want them to go out on their own
and leave the nest
one day and say thank you mom dad for
preparing me for this world and helping
me be who i am
so i can now go navigate on my own
that's what our parents want to do we
want to see our kids go
and leave the flock we want to see them
go their own way
i i this is a theory i have on um that i
believe
i know it's true for me and i think it's
true for for a lot of parents
and even us as a nation we raise our
kids in a structure
all right follow these rules stay within
these guidelines all right and if we do
that if the kids do that
they're gonna usually have a good chance
of succeeding
but what do we really want as parents
what do we really want as a nation
with governments and regulations hey
stay in line you got to follow the rules
yes do that but what we really want is
when our kid
or an entrepreneur comes to us and goes
thank you but i'm going my own way and
i'm not asking permission
that's when a mom and dad really go yes
and you are bluffing and if you do steve
jobs
i'm going to do wait a minute no you
can't do that yes i am he goes
all of a sudden he does it pulls it off
the world goes wow
[Music]
when i called my dad and told him i
didn't want to go to law school i want
to go to film school in that phone call
he could hear my voice that i really
wasn't asking him permission
i would have wobbling well i think i
maybe want to you know he just said boyd
nice pipe dream you're going to law
school like you planned but he heard my
voice
even though i was asking him a question
technically i wasn't asking permission
that's right you're asking for a
blessing that's a different thing right
yeah and then hearing that he was like
don't half-ass
and i heard riding going he felt like ah
i did a good job as a dad
that i raised my son in a structure long
enough you learn to block and tackle
before you go play wide out son right
raise the structure early you learn the
fundamentals and then if you want to let
it fly and go off on your own way go but
don't come a bluffing when you go
that's where the world's muffin too yeah
you can feel it right that's what your
agent told you right or your
uh buddy there in in hollywood at
out the gate people can smell
desperation
right you come out here needy you are
done
get out of here go go forget about
hollywood for a minute forget about
getting an agent
and i'll let you know when you're ready
when i came back and wasn't like i gotta
have an asian i gotta
that's when he said you're ready and he
was right man so
one of the things i did in lubbock i
actually worked at the law school there
at texas tech and one of the things i
did at night was i did
crisis work with the police department
i'd go do death notifications and be
with victims
and sit with folks in their darkest hour
we are obsessed as a culture with
talking in with the right answers and
just
running and running and running our
mouths and one of the things i learned
and dude i was the worst
the worst always had an answer always
had a witty smart comeback
always had the right thing to say i
thought right
and then you sit with somebody and their
child is passed away in that room
right there or their husband or wife is
no longer with us
one of the most poignant parts of your
book matthew was
i learned staring people in the face
there's nothing you can say
the only thing i can can give someone in
that moment as my
presence is this notion that you're not
alone
you tell a beautiful story about
suddenly people start recognizing you
and
this idea of hollywood had happened
right it happened the bomb goes off
and it's as beautiful and as a blessing
as we can imagine
and it's got a dark side to it and you
took off over to a place i've been to
off
in chama new mexico and you met brother
christian
and this idea of being known and being
heard basically through
silence tell me about that experience
so i just gotten famous all of a sudden
the world was a mirror
over one weekend was when the time to
kill came out over one weekend
my life changed all of a sudden i wasn't
meeting strangers anymore
everyone had a biography on me oh i'm
sorry matthew about miss hud
and i'm in my mind going number one
how'd you know it was matthew number two
how'd you know i had a dog number three
how do you know
her name was miss number four how did
you know she had cancer whoa that's a
lot man
yeah you're just trespassing on my
my life and and so i was getting a lot
of adulation as well i was getting
invited to do almost any script i wanted
where it's just two days before time to
kill came out i would have done any of
those scripts for nothing
and now they're all of them right i'm
like to have some discernment right now
to like choose what i want to do when
two days ago i would have done any of
these and now you're telling me i can do
all of them
i got to get out and go hear myself
think see what's going on i mean my feet
are off the ground a little bit
so i went away out there to the uh on
that chime rivet that monastery
and i and i just needed someone to talk
to
you know shake some monkeys off my back
the world wasn't making sense and and i
met this man brother christian
and we went for a walk about four hour
walk
and he listened hands behind back we
walked through that desert for four
hours and i
talk the entire time guilty thoughts
guilty actions what is right what's
making sense it's that the other i'm
confused
we finally come back around to the
chapel four hours later
and i mean my face is soaking wet dried
tears dust in them and everything else
and
i we sit down and i finish off my purge
my
confession basically and he hadn't said
one word in four hours
finally i finish and i'm looking at the
ground and i'm i'm
waiting this to dance yes
yes you are in trouble son here's what
you gotta do
nothing silent silence 15 seconds go by
i finally look up at him
he's just staring at me and he looks me
in the
eye and holds my eyeline for about three
seconds and he says
me too oh
i crumbled man i was like sometimes you
don't need a vibe
sometimes you need to be letting oh hey
man i just the human condition man i
will
we're we're all in it and and he let me
know
by saying that that while my problems
were specific to me they weren't
original they weren't i didn't have
i didn't have complete ownership of
those i didn't have the ownership of
that human condition everyone
feels different versions of that so he
spread it out and let me know
it's a human it's a it's it's part of
part of living man
part of being a human well and it
allowed me to forgive myself in certain
places and gave me the courage to change
certain things
that i need to change that theme of
of we're in it together just weaves its
way through your book and
um i i i'm of the belief that that's the
most
compassionate needed sentiment across
humanity in my own home
here at my office everywhere in my kids
schools is this notion that we're all in
this together
and whether it's your old man saying
don't go halfway
if you're gonna if you're gonna go go
right
and your mom's saying i love you and
you're better than that
and you're a guy saying don't let them
smell fear and then i'll introduce you
and then that monk and a monastery look
in your head saying hey man me too
and you have now given the
your readership a gift by saying hey i
know every single one of you is stuck
going too fast going too slow wherever
you may be me too
and i want to tell you man i'm grateful
for you appreciate your time
one of the uh things that we do to wrap
up this show every week
is man i'm a i'm a big music fan i come
from
a great music town there in texas there
in houston
and you come from the cornerstone of the
music city
so man give us give me
just a snippet of your favorite song
lyric of all time
by your favorite artist who would that
be
and when i say favorite by the way i
mean that in the texas way which means
about the top hundred
two hundred they're all but pretty much
my favorite right my favorite barbecue
place my favorite mexican food place
like what's your favorite
give me a song that has just rattled
around in your head
for your whole life oh
well for going texas-wise you know i'd
have to be crazy about willie nelson
finance as i crawled across the ground
i love that song but then you know what
in the theme of what we're talking about
my favorite song of all time and one
that is
we need to be listening to today more
pink houses john mellencamp hmm
yeah you got to snip it off top of your
head
black man with black cat living in a
black neighborhood
got an interstate running through his
front yard you know he thinks he's got
it so good
there's a woman in the kitchen cleaning
up the evening slop
you know looks at her and says i
remember when you could
stop climbing ain't that america
you and me ain't that america something
to see
ain't that america homie free yeah it'll
be
houses baby you and me
brother matthew thank you so so much for
giving me your most precious resource on
planet earth which is your time i'm
grateful for you man
thank you for bringing some joy into my
life with your book and your art
and um keep my state nice and
and warm and please for all is holy have
some queso for me
this week would you please do man
and all right now great grateful for you
man take care
all right cool so that was the one and
only matthew mcconaughey i hope you
enjoyed that conversation
hey listen that's the first interview
that we've pulled off on the dr john
deloney show
if you liked it send me a message shoot
me a note in the youtube chat
or on the direct messages on the
instagrams or whatever let me know if
you want to see more
interviews with me and my friends me and
matthew aren't friends but we are now
right
um it's so awesome to connect with you
good folks y'all be kind to one another
stay well be cool and i'll see you next
time on the dr john dolone show
[Music]